good things come to those who wait and
apparently those who take their thumb
off the camera this is not off to a good
start don't you hate it when people
start videos with platitudes said all
our YouTube and Here I am I know this
isn't the normal setup that we usually
have I'm just recording this on my phone
and I don't really know how to record
the phone I don't do a lot of selfie
action Happy New Year January 4th have
some major announcements to make I know
some of you before we get cross then are
you gonna be crossed because we were
supposed to start production up January
4th louder with crowd or the daily show
and at the website is under construction
but it's for its fur it's for a good
cause it's for a good reason and it it's
actually because of the overwhelming
support from you guys so let me explain
this to you really what we're gonna
start up February 1st ok I'll be on Joe
Rogan's show before that end of January
and then there are going to be some some
big big shows which I'll get to in a
second we have three new full-time hires
to bring in to loud it with Crowder to
train up because so many people join the
mug club and so many people enter the
golden ticket sweepstakes that we just
had a tough time going through them and
finding the right people so we're hiring
new editors we're hiring new production
managers and we're also I don't know if
you can see that it's kind of kind of a
little little anyway a little a little
messy and I think it Studios under
construction we're actually moving to a
whole new space because we've outgrown
this here and that again is because so
many people joined particularly during
the CNN live stream and something else I
don't think it's this bet based on
feedback spend can be there's gonna be
full time on air moving forward with the
daily show so there are a lot of these
things that just need to be incorporated
I can't say enough good things about the
team here behind the scenes I got to
tell you guys people here haven't taken
a week off and I mean a full week the
entire year we've missed shows and oh
people for example we would miss two
shows we say well where are you and then
the ant if a video would drop you know
when you only have a handful of people
working on these things and you're going
undercover you see like a YouTube Carol
it takes a lot of work because we're
aiming to try and elevate what we do
every day we could sit and talk to a
camera and we'd be fine and many of you
would be fine but the truth is there's
there's just an absolute absence of true
entertainment coming from the right and
a lot of people complained
it we want to do something about it and
that requires bringing in people and
listen we don't do patreon we don't we
don't give you guys you know five
minutes on skype if you give a certain
amount we try and repay people with with
real paying jobs no one needs to fight
for 15 here at ladder with Crowder
because everyone all the way down to the
day rate interns are paid much more than
15 an hour and it's over a dozen people
now who we employ and our goal is to to
grow that you know I think they say like
four hours of prep for every hour on air
for radio and that that sounds about
right having done radio certainly I
spend probably more time in prep them
than most because I needed more current
than most we did 16 hours of the scene
in live stream but we weren't just doing
radio you know we had dwarf Jesus and
Santa wrestling for the spirit of
Christmas we had guests after guests
after guests we had Carol it was a lot
of work we had a film with the YouTube
Carol that went up in it really
overextended us in in some ways ways
that we need to fix with bringing in new
people we know that we need the help and
we had to go through the golden ticket
sweepstakes and something else some
other big announcements we've been
talking about this and I felt bad
because you know what we want to get the
show on the road and people been asking
I can't tell you the number of requests
to to come to schools I haven't been
able to go do any live performances
because this show is taking up every
single minute of my time for the last
year and we haven't been able to figure
out how to bring the show on the road
because we're doing a show every single
day so we haven't had time but now with
this construction phase we will actually
be bringing a lot of with Crowder to
your school on the road we're going to
have those capabilities the very first
is going to be February 6th at Virginia
Tech so we'll be broadcasting this show
from Virginia Tech on February 6th and
that's something new moving forward we
can do Q&A the the jokes the sketches
you're gonna see all that at your school
we can't thank you enough honestly we
had so many people who joined from
escena over a million people I think I
don't know who I'm looking to there's no
one here they're all out this is just me
talking I just feels kind of nice just
talking into a camera with nobody else
in a room I I guess I get why people do
this I don't need to put on a a robe and
makeup could just talk to a camera and
collect your check pass go but so many
people joined because of the CNN stream
it was it was tough I would rather be
waterboarded
and as those words leave my mouth I
realize there's not a hint of hyperbole
I've been waterboarded I would rather be
waterboarded again for a much longer
period of time than watch CNN for 16
hours it got to the point after that
live stream you ever eat so much of
something when you're a kid and you get
sick that you can't even look at it
after that that was me would see it was
playing at some relative I don't know
CNN was on somewhere and I looked at it
and I was like it was like ah how can
you even think of macaroni and cheese
like you had the flu like I can't even
look at anymore but I think it proves
the point as to just how bad media is
and how biased it is and listen we're
not aiming here we're not aiming to just
be another YouTube channel and the
growth there has been unbelievable but
we are aiming to not take out but but to
compete with the people on late-night to
compete with the scene ends of the world
people talk about who cares about the
Young Turks there's so far in our rear
view mirror in many ways and they will
be in a long time but we're well we're
trying to create the kind of content
that we always wished was out there I
would listen I was in college I was a
conservative right I never went to a lot
of the college Republican meetings I
didn't fit in there I didn't want to put
on a bow tie and be you know the Tucker
Carlson look-alike convention circuit
crossfire back when the bow tie was his
shtick I wished that there were a
conservative Letterman back then or
Conan or actual late-night that's what I
wash I feel like there are a lot of
people out there that's what there's
been so much support and that's what
we're aiming for
that's why we're growing that's why
we're going into a new space that's why
we're hiring three new people when you
invest and you join for the daily show
which don't you don't this is not a
pitch that you'll have to do that though
I will say the new a lot of credit
sketch shirt is up at the merch store
you are investing in and not only
influence or allowing us to to create an
impact and to fight back against all the
people who've pissed us off for years
you're also employing people here people
who make good livings for their family
it has been so remarkable people have
needed this time now just we can't do a
Daily Show just during this month and
make the changes that we need to make
we're actually flying some people across
the country and some people aren't on
work visas to move to US and work for
the program we can't do both at the same
time we even ran
I think we ran out of storage space for
some of our archive shows like we this
is a long time coming but the growth I
can't show it to you right now because
this is completely unedited as I'm gonna
try and find my computer it's not around
or an overlay right well this is one of
the few shows where we do we do overlays
spend computers been working behind the
scenes now he'll be in front of the
camera where we try and show you the
sources but I remember we set out we
started the Daily Show last January mid
January and I wrote down some goals at
that point and and knock easier than I
wrote down like a you know what we think
would be you know top tier goal like
850,000 YouTube subscribers and then a
certain amount of paying mug club people
and then we wrote like dream goal
something that would be awesome we
didn't was a million subscribers and we
ended the year with one point one
seventy-five 1 million a hundred
thousand and seven hundred one million
one hundred seventy-five thousand
subscribers it's far beyond what we
expected and louder with CARICOM is
doing incredibly well and we've just
right now we've got to basically able to
meet to we need our capacity to be able
to meet the requirements from you guys
we want to be able to do not only the
daily show but bringing new people hire
new people start new programs but first
step is is making sure that we can get
this out on time get it out that's you
know in a way that's top quality and be
able to bring this show on the road to
you we can't thank you enough people
who've joined at lotto Scudder calm /
mug club during the YouTube squeeze when
everyone else has been having to buckle
down we've been able to grow and just
just explode and the possibilities and
the ideas and that's because you really
have supported us behind the scenes
that's what's going on right now for
people who are we're still gonna have
some I think some videos here like some
some updates until February 1st like I
said Joe Rogan before then I'll be on
his show taking the show on the road
after that and for those who are mudkip
subscribers we might do some live kind
of Q&A is in this under construction
studio in the interim and of course
those who watch the daily show you know
where to submit your golden ticket
applications we actually do have one
more hire that we need to make and we
haven't decided on that yet so that's
gonna be February 1st when the daily
show comes back we'll have probably some
other videos but this is this is all
because I can't even begin to anticipate
what we'll do in 2018 I I know it could
all go away tomorrow
we all know that we try to act as though
that's the case we feel as though we
need to earn your subscribership every
single day every show we feel as though
we need to earn your mug club dollar
every day we never want to take it for
granted and so this is next level
onward and upward and we are so excited
to to bring in new faces to bring in new
hires incredibly talented people and to
hopefully impress you guys and make you
feel as though you've gotten your
money's worth and dear God please don't
make me watch CNN for 16 hours again I
really don't want to do that